I am
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
the child killer who walked free for 30
years finally convicted of the murder of
his seven-year-old victim
why wasn't
his grandparents
looked at
Nikki Allen's family tell us they now
have justice but also question why
police fail to find her killer many
years ago also tonight
why economic growth is on strike the
evidence that industrial unrest and high
inflation are holding back the economy
on the offensive in eastern Ukraine as
Russia admits its soldiers have been
forced back around back much
the conservative police and crime
commissioner who triggered
investigations into his political
opponents revealed by Sky News
[Music]
and no point for politics while the
organizers of Eurovision won't let
Ukraine's president speak
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's in the
Press preview from half past 10.
[Music]
hello very good evening a child killer
who was able to live free for decades
was finally convicted today David Boyd
murdered seven years old Nikki Allen in
1992. despite already having convictions
involving underage girls he was seen as
a witness rather than a suspect by
police at the time today his victim's
family told us they finally had justice
but questioned why officers hadn't
brought into account before Katarina
vitotsu reports from Newcastle Crown
Court
time hasn't diminished the brutality of
this crime in 1992 seven-year-old Nikki
Allen was abducted viciously beaten and
repeatedly stabbed
her body left in the basement of an
abandoned building close to her home in
Sunderland
a year after her murder one man was
tried but found not guilty the mystery
of who did this haunting Nikki's family
for decades
today David Boyd was finally found
guilty of her murder I feel amazing
honestly I can't even explain how I feel
ecstatic never thought I would have
heard that I would start to give up
after 25 years
starting to give a pop and that he was
seven I was 99 so she was really close
to me like I've lost nearly half
never thought it would come yeah it's
just a little yelling
yeah David Boyd is now 55. he first
became a suspect in 2018
okay of that offense you do not have to
see it at the time of Nikki's
disappearance Boyd lived in the same
block of flats as her family was dating
her babysitter and the prosecution said
this photo from when Boyd was in his 20s
match the description from a witness
who'd seen a man walking with a young
girl on the night Nikki was killed when
he was murdered why wasn't
he looked in why wasn't that addressed
three doors from his grandparents
looked at during this trial the jury and
Nikki's mum learned that David Boyd had
been previously convicted for sexually
assaulting a young girl and that he told
a social worker he'd had sexual
fantasies about children
is gone and
it should have been just as years ago
do anything
I'm getting out of this is my daughter's
my grand kids done it after five for
justice I fought so hard
David Boyd's DNA was found on Nikki's
clothes and police matched it using
technology that simply didn't exist 30
years ago but Nikki's family believed
that the initial police investigation
was insufficient and failed to take into
account things like witness statements
from the night she disappeared
but today please describe this as one of
the most complex cold cases their Force
has ever handled Nikki Allen would have
been 37 now and who knows what her life
could have been
the pain and suffering that he has
caused unto so many people is
immeasurable
when the guilty verdict was delivered in
court Nikki Allen's family stood up and
shouted from them really there was just
one word justice
Katrina Novato see Sky News Newcastle
now you might think it's remarkable the
economy grew at all in the first three
months of this year with the war in
Ukraine stubbornly High food and fuel
prices and Strikes which kept many
people off the trains and forced
millions of parents to take time off to
stay at home looking after their
children well the economy did grow
however from January to March though by
the smallest amount measurable just 0.1
percent however the economy shrank in
March by 0.3 percent largely due to
Falls in retail and car sales and the
public sector strikes there were more of
those today with train drivers returning
to the picket lines as our business and
economics correspondent gurpreet narwan
reports
the trains are coming to a halt and so
is the economy
many businesses are counting the cost
fewer people are visiting and they've
got less to spend
on Saturdays business at this gift shop
is down by half I've just noticed that
the days where the strikes are happening
are my quietest days and obviously over
the last few months has been tube and
bus as well having strikes but the
trains have had the biggest impact it
just means that how can we survive how
can we pay our bills if people do not
come in
even when the trains are running people
are hardly in the mood to spend wages
aren't keeping up with inflation and
workers like Flora have had enough we
are striking as teachers because
teachers are being asked to do more and
more with less and less we tighten our
belts we think very carefully about the
food that we buy
um I have colleagues who do second jobs
and work in a supermarket I have
colleagues who visit food banks the
teachers aren't alone industrial action
is Rife across the public sector a sign
of the economic turmoil we Face the
economy is flagging under the strain of
high inflation and high taxes which is
leaving people with less disposable
income each month no wonder they're
protesting about this decline in their
living standards but strikes like these
are doing damage of their own to the
economy
GDP has still not recovered to its
pre-pandemic size first lockdowns cause
growth to plummet but the country is now
battling other economic shocks including
brexit and the Ukraine war
ministers however are focusing on the
positives these are much better figures
than anyone would possibly have
predicted even three months ago but
there is still much work to do we still
have inflation that is much too high
that's causing a lot of pressure for
families up and down the country that's
why we've got to stick to our plan to
get inflation down to get growth up and
to get the economy Motoring in the way
that we all want
inflation was a major topic of
conversation at a meeting of G7 Finance
ministers in Japan
but despite his optimistic comments few
among them will have been feeling these
economic woes as acutely as Jeremy Hunt
Gareth now on Sky News
Ukraine has made gains close to the city
of bakmut in what could be the sign of
the beginning of its long promised
offensive at these pictures released by
the Ukrainian military show what it says
are its troops advancing in the region
Russia's defense minister acknowledged
its forces in one area had fallen back
Ukraine though faces some significant
challenges in claiming back land as our
military analyst Michael Clarke now
explains
the next few days and weeks in Ukraine
are likely to be a picture of confusion
with different messaging about who's
advancing where now there are two likely
strategic aims to Ukraine firstly to
reclaim the donbass in the East that
after all is the area that Russia says
it wants to occupy so the ukrainians
want to throw the Russians out of that
area but secondly Ukraine could regain a
tremendous Advantage by cutting off the
land bridge between this area which
includes the key city of Melita Paul and
the strategically important safaricia
nuclear power station right down to the
coast and if they could break up this
land bridge between Ukraine and Crimea
then that would weaken Russia's lines
tremendously and it would be a great
political benefit to the ukrainians an
offensive in the South rather than the
East might also be easier due to more
favorable ground conditions for heavy
equipment like battle tanks and
artillery so here is a satellite image
of topnak in the south in zaprasia
oblast now if you look very closely the
bass lines that look almost like
scratches along the land they're the The
Trenches the defensive that the Russians
have already dug and built in but let's
encourage in yellow the extent of the
network that we know is there this is
what they've really built there that we
know of and then of course put in the
water put in the rivers that are also in
that area and then coloring in in red
The High Ground because The High Ground
is critical for both attack and defense
whoever controls The High Ground has got
observation they've got the artillery
Advantage it really matters and so you
can see that any commander wanting to
take this area has got to get over the
water they've got to actually get round
the defenses they've got to capture The
High Ground And The Defenders will be
working with all of those things to
prevent that from happening which is why
as the uh ukrainians think about their
heavy metal all their tanks and armored
vehicles they've also got to think about
their bridging equipment their
engineering all the technical things
that allow their heavy metal to actually
do the job now the weather is improving
in this area it's about 20 degrees at
the moment it's going to be about 25
degrees in two weeks time it's drying up
the ground is drying out so it's perfect
for armored vehicles so the time is now
for this sort of offensive to take place
but when it does it will be like a chess
game between one commander and another
each trying to out think the other in
the use of the ground the water the
defenses and The High Ground and this
will be taking place all through Ukraine
not just in the South around Melita pole
but all through Ukraine wherever the
ukrainians think they can break through
it'll be a series of little chess games
between one commander and another
Michael Clarke with that analysis
turkey's president erdogan has become
synonymous with his country during his
20 years at the top but he's facing
perhaps his greatest challenge in
elections on Sunday and the man who
might defeat him has told Sky News he
wants Freedom not authoritarian
leadership our Europe correspondent Adam
Parsons spoke to him and sent this
report from Istanbul
this is Istanbul's newest mosque and
today opened by reject type erdogan
for two decades the president has
reshaped turkey
giving himself vast power disrupting
Global diplomacy picking battles with
the West
he's now ging up his supporters for the
weekend's presidential election
[Applause]
three hours away in the city of Bursa
support amid the bustle
holder tells me he loves the president
from the heart that he'd vote for him a
million times if he could
but in truth erdogan's grip on power is
under strain
his political opponents have United
behind a single candidate his name is
Kamal kilistarolo and he tells me his
country's been broken by erdogan's bull
turkey
yes
he tells me he will reconcile his
country support Sweden joining NATO and
repair turkey's fractured international
relations
are you worried about any dirty tricks
on the day of the election
foreign
turkey's opposition parties will come up
to this stage to deliver one her final
speeches before Sunday's election and
that is the scene that will greet him
thousands of thousands of his supporters
increasingly confident that he will be
the next president
tells them to work for a brighter future
his logo is a heart symbol many here see
him as the opportunity for a new start
I am 44 years old 20 years maybe the
best years of my life have been spent
under oppression and intimidation and in
an atmosphere of crisis
could be the country's next president or
just another footnote in erdogan's story
of dominance this is a desperately close
election in a chronically divided nation
Adam Parson Sky News bursa
Pakistan's former prime minister Imran
Khan said the country's Judiciary was
the only hope now left after a court
ordered that he should be freed on bail
it follows days of protest and violence
at his treatment that the government
blamed on him our correspondent Cordelia
Lynch sent this report from Islamabad
it has been a tumultuous week for
former prime minister this a full circle
moment Imran Khan back at the place
where he was first arrested this time
hoping to be freed whilst taking aim at
those who detained him
at home I was inside the high court they
had no justification for my arrest they
abducted me the first time they showed
me an arrest warrant was inside the jail
it happened in the law of the jungle
but he does still have faith in one
institution I must say I expected this
from a judiciary
because the only hope now left the only
thin line between a Banana Republic
and democracy is that Judiciary that's
the only hope we have now otherwise
there is no rule of law here
the Judiciary has given him some respite
Mr Khan granted two weeks bail but Imran
Khan is far from out of the woods the
threat of being rearrested hangs heavily
over him but that comes with the degree
of risk for the government too this is
an election year
the government is trying to focus its
message on the violence not the arrest
the attacks on sensitive buildings and
installations were called carried out
planned who was the planner in Randy
artsy who was instigator imranliatsi
it is a complex game of chess ahead one
thought the danger Imran Khan needs to
inspire not in sight the government
needs to keep a popular opponent at Bay
and still convince the country it can be
fair
untrusted Cordelia Lynch Sky News
Islamabad Pakistan
back here and Sky News has discovered
that a well-connected conservative
police and crime commissioner triggered
two different police investigations into
his political opponents in recent weeks
Steve Turner was campaigning to become a
Tory counselor in the local elections
his opponents found themselves
investigated by Cleveland Police the
same force Mr Turner oversees our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates reports
I woke up to a couple of early modern
calls I'm missed on my mobile and it was
the fraud police hundreds of miles from
Westminster politics and power exist
away from the glare of the national
Spotlight I was frustrated this man ran
Labor's local election campaign in the
Northeast town of redcar just over a
week before polling day fraud police
arrived on his doorstep and said they
were investigating his campaign leaflets
two playing Clause policemen came into
my front room I was sat down and I did
feel a little bit paused on customer you
know that was stood up I did feel
interrogated slightly
that visit and police visits to the
homes of two other labor activists
triggered by this man Steve Turner Not
only was he their rival Tory election
candidate he is also the police and
crime commissioner for this area it's an
excellent job really enjoying it it's
everything I expected to be and more a
job that means he oversees the very
officers investigating his opponents
following his complaint
on Tuesday he failed to get elected as a
counselor losing in a third recount to
the same labor activists that were
investigated Steve Turner told Sky News
he complained to the council about this
labor leaflet and that it was standard
for the complaint to be passed to the
police
fraud officers told one of the activists
that they were there because the leaflet
had upset Steve and no action would be
taken but Mr Turner told us that he did
not direct the police response Cleveland
Police said that the inquiries were
routine his wife also standing
unsuccessfully in the same ward defended
his conduct my husband was a candidate
in this race and he has every right the
same as any other member of the public
to repart offenses to the police
you don't think that there is an evident
conflict of interest involving the
police getting the council to involve
the police in a race in which he is
involved I do not know if it was a
conflict of interest that would mean
that I would never be able to report any
crime that was happening to me as an
individual on his on his Facebook page
he said that the police agreed that
there was disinformation how did he come
to that judgment
no comment
what's striking is the scale of
involvement from Cleveland Police three
separate visits to three different labor
party members even though the police are
quite upfront with them there was no
offense committed and then they phoned
Tori Steve Turner with a readout of what
went on could this have anything to do
with the Tory candidate also having
oversight of the people in the building
behind me
Sky News has discovered a second
political opponent of Steve Turner was
investigated by police after Turner made
a harassment complaint via the local 101
hotline
police told the individual there was no
case to answer
some claim Turner's Behavior could
amount to an abuse of power the
perception is that he abused his power
in this case he you know nobody else
would have got the
level of attention that the police gave
him and this allegation that he got and
that clearly demonstrates that he had
the power to make it happen whereas you
and I wouldn't have would never have
been able to do that this episode
revealed by a quirk a focus on redcar as
the final election result to declare
does sunlight shine often enough in all
parts of our democracy
Sam coat Sky News red car
police are preparing to dig for the
remains of a missing student after an
alleged confession to her Murder By
serial killer Levi bellfield in an
interview with detectives this week the
former nightclub bouncer said that he
had hidden her body in Woodland 24 years
ago the 54 year old is serving a whole
life sentence for the murders of two
young women and the school girl Millie
Dollar in 2002.
Elon Musk has announced that the former
head of advertising at NBC Linda
yacarino is the new CEO of Twitter musk
the current chief executive tweeted that
yakarino will mainly focus on business
operations while he focuses on product
design and new technology
the Archbishop of Canterbury has been
convicted of speeding just days after
leading the coronation of the king
Justin Welby was ordered to pay 510
pounds for exceeding a 20 mile an hour
limit in the Kennington area of London
last October
the way America can prevent migrants
Crossing from Mexico is in a state of
flux tonight regulations which dated
from Donald Trump's presidency ran out
last night replaced with new rules
introduced by President Biden our U.S
correspondent James Matthews is in Texas
for us tonight James
thank you very much indeed uh Jonathan
yes the Department of Homeland Homeland
Security in the United States it's
saying today that I didn't see any surge
at the midnight moment when the
so-called title 42 ran out but what it
can deny is that there has been a record
surge Daily Record figures of migrants
crossing the border in the run-up to
that midnight moment when the law
changed now we've spent the day here in
New Mexico on the mountain that looms
large over the U.S Mexico border let's
have a look now at a day in the life of
Mount Crystal rain
a helicopter and to the right an officer
on Horseback conduct border patrol high
on Mount Crystal Ray where America meets
Mexico
with our cameras we found what they were
looking for migrants concealed among
rocks one in the middle watching us with
binoculars
they didn't care for the reverse angle
one throwing a stone at the Drone
by vehicle Border Patrol Chase reports
of migrants on the ground
while the helicopter continued its
search by air and they kept coming
more
and yet more
it's easy to see why migrants would
choose this route to make a border
crossing much of the border is lined by
this a 21-foot high fence but take a
look here at this particular Point what
separates America from Mexico is
concrete a foot high
on the mountain where they couldn't
build a wall border crossing is a daily
routine and it's where migrants see a
clear path to the United States
a white marker high up denotes the U.S
border to be here is to see the
difficulty in stemming the flow of
immigration title 42 or not
when the old law passed U.S Homeland
Security said there had been no
substantial increase in migrant numbers
but they've acknowledged failings over
time our system has been broken for more
than two decades it was last reformed in
the 1990s so that is the first point the
second point is we have not received
from Congress the resources that we need
and that we requested it is a political
story that grows with the numbers
they kept on coming over Mount Crystal
Ray towards New Mexico
the Mountain's reminder that this is a
tale with people at its heart
well there you go it was a busy day that
was one sector of the border at New
Mexico and speak to border patrol
officers and they tell you that some
days they can be chasing up to 500
migrants and that's the day after title
42 so on the face of it here and it is a
microcosm there's no great change with
the law uh the challenge for Joe Biden
is considerable of course he is
reinforcing the message that there will
be tough new restrictions he's talking
about the expulsion of migrants who
don't apply for Asylum before they get
into the United States and who don't
apply online saying that they could be
expelled for five years and not allowed
to return if they do they could be
criminally prosecuted so that has
prompted a fear amongst migrants that
entry restrictions could be tougher
following the end of title 42 that
clearly has fueled a surge of sorts of
that we've seen in recent days and weeks
that's been compounded by misinformation
provided by human Smugglers so that is
the basis on which we have seen the
Practical experience here it is big on
politics clearly it will be one of the
defining issues of the coming election a
defining issue of the future for
President Joe Biden
James thank you James Matthews there in
Texas
finally the president just wants to show
his love and thank the UK so let him
speak so so the Eurovision I shudder to
say Legends jedward who are unlikely
allies of Rishi sunak but speaking to
Sky News they backed the prime
minister's call for Vladimir zielinski
to be allowed to address the song
contest audience tomorrow night the
organizers say he won't be allowed to in
Liverpool the performers are getting
ready as our arts and entertainment
correspondent Katie Spencer now reports
belting out Eurovision Classics in the
street
if you're a fan what more could you want
a reliable public train Network you say
has left the first ones to score nil POI
with fans here but that's not stopping
standing hosts Liverpool from going for
it
[Music]
the UK's entered May Muller itching to
get started I thought I was excited
before but now I'm here I'm even more
excited and I feel like I'm just ready
to go now it's been so much build up and
then now I'm like it's basically here
for the first time we can show you this
a sneak peek at rehearsals and what the
160 million viewers expected to tune in
we'll see the production is immense
imagine being on the lighting desk with
000 lighting cues programmed in it's no
spoiler to say this is going to be
spectacular our concept and the
architecture of our set revolves around
a big hug I see if Liverpool is
welcoming the Ukraine uh Europe and the
world with big Open Arms incorporating
Ukraine is music and people is Central
to what you'll see in the show but
Richie soon acts seemingly wanting in on
the action after hosting his own
Eurovision reception wading into the
decision of organizers not to let
president zielinski make an address over
concerns the event could become too
politicized insisting the values of what
the ukrainians are fighting for are not
political they're fundamental Eurovision
veterans jedward I think he might have a
point yeah I think it'd be like a great
way to thank the UK for hosting it for
Ukraine and I feel like the president
it's not so political I think he just
wants to share his love and thank the UK
for doing such a great job the show will
include 11 Ukrainian acts opening with
last year's winners kalusha Orchestra
we would like to say please vote for our
Ukrainian band don't forget about
Ukraine and keep supporting us
this wouldn't be a party without the
prospect
ripping none of us will ever forget you
know we can remember every minute of it
so and it will be the same for them but
it's bigger better more extraordinary
more fun boy and more colorful more
fantastic now than it ever was get ready
to sing dance and bask in Eurovision and
all its Camp pop Glory Liverpool is
laying on quite the party Katie Spencer
Sky News in Liverpool